A început să plouă destul de puternic.
De fapt, plouă. Îi dă cu piatră. A
început să i dea cu piatră. E vreun sil
al treilea pește în jumătate de oră.
Oho,
Narcis ăsta cred că are vreo 6 7 kg.
Vă salut, dragi pescari. Suntem din nou
în Delta Dunării. De data asta am venit
înainte de prohibiție. Am zis că
să mai prindem două trei zile de
pescuit, un pescuit foarte greu. Am
ajuns acum două zile. În prima zi ne am
plimbat
exagerat de mult. Am fost pe
[voce dreasă] aproape de lacul Fortuna,
după care am ajuns pe Boda Proste. După
Boda Proste am luat o spre Lopatna. De
pe Lopatna iar pe Boda Proste. Deci
efectiv în prima zi ne am plimbat ne am
plimbat peste tot. Crapul l am găsit
foarte greu. Am
găsit câteva zone unde am văzut crapi.
Am încercat acolo. Nu am avut nicio
trăsătură. Ieri am venit pe un canal
unde a pescuit Vali de la Aventuri cu
gust. Vali a avut o super partidă. El a
plecat ieri și mi a predat mie locul și
îi mulțumesc pe calea asta. Adică îi
mulțumesc. Vali, mersi pentru pentru că
mi ai lăsat locul. Ieri am pescuit aici
pe locul lui Vali și am avut doar trei
trăsături, dintre care am scos doi
ciortani și până acum am fost urmăriți
de ghinioane.
Două ratări, unul Narcis l a ratat mai
devreme și asta doar ce am aruncat o și
efectiv din zbor a luat o.
Nu este mare,
dar pe praful ăsta e ce trebuie. Știți
cum e vorba aia, am prins caraj mai mari
ca ăsta, dar după ce ieri n am prins
niciun pește, astăzi n am scos niciun
pește, am avut două rateuri. Ăsta ne
aduce așa un pic de bucurie. Hai să l
eliberăm.
Și azi dimineață am zis hai să venim.
Nu, încă nu știm dacă să rămânem și
astăzi să mai stăm până mâine.
Am zis că în funcție de pește și am
venit dimineață la 7:30 aveam bețele
băgate în apă. A plouat destul de
puternic în jur de două ore nici n am
reușit să dau drumul la cameră. După
care s a oprit ploaia și când s a oprit
ploaia am început și trăsăturile. Am
avut trei trăsături,
aș zice relativ una după alta.
Ia, ia ține, ține
[voce dreasă]
de aici de sub noi.
Lasă că l scot eu.
Mamă, ia uite l trage cu barca. Bă,
>> dă i f
>> I am dat, i am dat.
Dragi pescari, al treilea pește în
jumătate de oră. După ce am stat două
ore fără o trăsătură, se pare că i am
găsit traseul.
Asta e tot la peleta de 15 căpșună. Tot
la 15 căpșună au venit celelalte două
trăsături
și hai să vedem ce pește este.
Oho!
Narcisul ăsta cred că are vreo 6 7 kg.
Ia să vedem, dragi pescari.
Ce frumos e băiatule.
Bun. Ia vedeți, dragi pescari, cred că
are un 6 kg, dar având în vedere că am
alergat două zile după el, este foarte,
foarte bine.
Îl am alături de mine pe Narcis de la
Bacău. Este un pescar înrăit și el și
are și magazin de pescuit în Bacău, unde
bineînțeles, găsiți toate produsele
noastre. Cei care nu știți, am văzut că
sunt mult mulți care comandă din Bacău
la noi pe site, așa că puteți să mergeți
și la Narcis în Magazin să le găsiți
acolo.
Al treilea pește.
I am găsit oarecum culoarul pe unde
trece el.
trece cumva efectiv prin spatele bărcii.
Cioata este în fața noastră
și trăsăturile au venit de aici dintre
noi și cioci
al treilea pește, dragi pescari. Ha, să
vedem cât este cât este ceasul, că s
curios. Este 9:40.
Patru trăsături de la 7:30 până acum. Eu
zic că este bine. Dacă menține frecvența
asta până
până după amiază, până la 3 4 ar fi ar
fi o partidă reușită. Ar fi o zi
reușită. Hai să vedem ce se mai
întâmplă.
Las
>> Deci, dra dragi pescari, cât a trecut? 5
10 minute. 5 10 minute.
>> Deci doar pe lanseta asta.
>> [sforăit]
>> Ăsta e mai micuț.
E la vreun kilogram așa, 1,g.
Le eliberăm repede și să vină alții mai
mari.
>> [muzică]
>> Ia l, mă, ia l că i acolo.
Este
>> mai trebuia lăsat un pic.
>> Nu, mă, că era cu ea în gură, mă.
Terminați cu lăsatul ăsta. Era cu ea în
gură.
El absoarbe, absoarbe, expiră. Absoarbe,
expiră. În momentul în care tu ai văzut
trăsătura, când tu ai văzut trăsătura,
el deja dă din cap să scape de ea. Adică
el are cârligul în gură. Adică tu atunci
îl iei.
>> Da, dar când am pus eu mâna pe lansuță
nu mai făcea nimic.
>> O scuip asta de genul.
Dar nu ți o mai lua?
>> Că m am uitat și [voce dreasă] la vârf
nu mai făcea nimic.
>> Păi o scuipase deja. Dar asta să să ți
iasă din cap chestia asta. Mai lasă l,
mai lasă l, mai lasă l. Îl lași în
momentul în care vezi că e trăsătură
așa. Dar dacă el face așa, e clar că el
dă din cap. Adică gândește te la ce se
întâmplă sub apă. Știi ce zic?
>> Da.
A mai fost o trăsătură. A încercat
Narcis să l să l scoată. Din păcate
n a luat o bine. Asta e. S a dezgățat.
Deci a mai fost o trăsătură.
Narcis a tot insistat să dăm la căpșună
la roșu pentru că a văzut că trăsăturile
au venit. Toate veniseră până acum pe
roșu și i a tot insistat când am
schimbat. Zice: „Bagă i tot căpșună
roșu. Bagă i tot căpșună roșu. Zic:
„Stai mă liniștit că nu i problemă că o
ia și pe asta. și i am băgat Secret
Aroma galben. Și acuma i am zis, vezi că
merge și pe asta. Nu i problemă. Ideea e
să dai de pește. Ideea e să fii pe
traseul lui pe unde vine el sau unde
vine el să se hrănească. Îia și roșu, ia
și galben.
Ești convins? Narțisa acum. Deci e ok.
Rămânem așa. Da.
>> Prietenia e prietenie, bă. Businessul e
business fără supărare și trezi
la mare.
>> Vezi că ai firul subțire, e drumul la
fel.
Și vezi că se duce niciodată acolo. Nu,
mai în față. Intră mai în față.
A mai venit un pește.
De data asta nis la butoane.
N are ce să adu aici. Te ajut eu.
Dă i un pic de frână dacă crezi că mai
trebuie.
Bă, nu se poate.
>> O să arăt pe filmare cum ai tras de ele.
[râsete]
A scăpat. E al tre E al treilea pește pe
care î scapă. Narcis.
>> Am văzut. Ai făcut și tu. Am văzut. Ai
luat inițiativa. Sunt foarte mândru de
tine. Am văzut. Ai dat drumul la frână.
>> Bă, dar nu era agățat.
>> Da, mă, dar nu era agățat. Ce? Păi, n ai
văzut la mine când m a tras ăla că s a
plimbat? Nu, acuma serios vorbesc. Îmi
vine să râd, dar vorbesc serios. Ai
văzut și ăla de l ai spus tu? Nu. Și ăla
de la lus. Ai văzut cum era agățat? N
avea cum să scape.
>> Nu e nu și agață bine. N ai ce să faci.
Asta e.
>> Nu, mă, dar cum îi dau un pic drumul la
Chiar dacă lăsam vârful complet în apă,
el nu trebuia să scăsească prin cârl.
>> N are treaba asta cu vârful.
Ia uite trăsătură
>> este.
>> Da.
E pornit. Camera merge.
A mai venit unul, dragi pescari.
Căpșunică 15. Mai devreme Narcis a avut
unul la peletă de 10 Secret Aromă
galben.
Față de ieri și alalti. Chiar suntem
foarte bine. Astăzi am avut activitate.
Eu sunt super mulțumit de partidă până
acum.
Ne a luat două zile să l găsim. Mi a
luat două zile să ne concentrăm, dar
uite că am reușit.
Este, mă,
n a mai venit de mustăcios.
Are și ăsta vreo 2 kg jumate.
>> Trei.
>> N are ce zice că are trei.
Avem o activitate. E ok.
>> [muzică]
>> Ce credeți? A început să plouă destul de
puternic. De fapt, plouă. Îi dă cu
piatră. A început să i dea cu piatră.
Na, ăsta i sezonul. Ce să i facem?
Așteptăm să vedem. Poate intră acum ceva
mare pe piatra asta.
>> [muzică]
>> Că e mai bine și pentru tine și pentru
ei.
>> Spun, bă, gustul e neutru.
Ia uite, ăsta a fost mare.
>> Da.
>> La care vine? Trebuie să vină la una din
al
>> e aici la Dragi pescari, toată ziua
peștele s a s a mișcat. A sărit ba pe
acolo, ba pe acolo, ba pe lângă stuf, ba
în fața noastră. Acuma sper că s a văzut
pe cameră. A sărit un pește în fața
noastră. Ă, o să văd la filmări dacă
dacă reușesc să l dacă se vede pe
cameră, o să montez în așa fel încât să
vedeți și voi. Deci, fix în fața
noastră, fix unde dăm noi lansetele, v
am zis, le dăm din mână. Patru dintre
ele le dăm așa din pe sub mână, le dăm
în spatele bărcii și de aici vin peștii.
Peștii presupun că au un culoar. Au
culoarul care trec pe lângă stuf. Aici
în fața noastră este cioata.
Ăsta î luam și eu ăla cât s a dus agățat
cu vârful în jos.
Oho!
Uite, bă, ce sportiv e.
Doar ce am aruncat o? Nu, Narcis.
>> Da.
Poate și partea asta aud. Stai un pic,
stai un pic, stai să liniștim un pic.
Un alt ciortănaș
a venit la nici cinci minute după ce am
lansat.
Hai să ne vedem. Tot sperăm că ne vine
și nouă ceva mai mare.
L am împins așa un pic ca să nu cadă pe
aici, să lovească și am reușit. L am dat
direct în apă. Deci a fost eliberat în
siguranță. Noi ținem scorul aici. Narcis
ține scorul. Narcis cât? Nouă trăsături.
Șapte pe scoși. Nu
>> scoși.
>> Bravo!
[muzică]
E
eu
ăsta nu i
>> cum e mai mare
>> cum e.
A mai venit un pește.
Dar bătăios.
>> Da, așa sunt.
>> Ăsta nu merge. Nu știu cum. Hai, bagă
ăla
în ciocul.
>> Stai așa că nu pot să trec de tine.
>> Hai, ridică l.
>> Pune te tu jos ca să nu răsturnăm barca.
A, n am scăpat.
Avem activitate. Cât sunt Narcis? 10.
>> Opt.
>> Opt scoși.
>> Au fost nouă trăsături. Șapte scoși.
>> Acum 10 trăsături. Acum 10 trăsături cu
opt scoși.
>> E ok. E ok pentru perioada asta. E
foarte bine.
>> Mamă!
Foarte nașpa. Nu nașpa.
Cu gheață
început ola acuma de
>> Iar îi dă cu gheață.
>> Nu te auzi.
>> Deci, dragi pescari, avem început o
super furtună.
Îi dă cu piatră, bate vântul. Voi nu
vedeți pe camere, dar este super nasol.
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> Deci azi avem toate anotimpurile.
Am avut dimineață ploaie, frig, după
care am avut furtună,
am avut grindină,
acum avem soare. Mai devreme iar am avut
soare și tot așa. Cred că așa ne ține
toată ziua.
Uite.
>> Mhm.
>> Da, da,
dar e tot așa. Mamă, din ce în ce mai
mici, mă.
Narcis.
>> Stai așa.
>> Deci, din ce în ce mai mici. Ia uită te.
Vezi?
12 trăsături. Și ăsta a fost ăsta a fost
al nouălea pește. Uitați vă și voi la
el. parcă vin din ce în ce mai mici. Nu
știm ce se întâmplă, dar oricum, fiind
ultima zi, n avem ce face. O să rămânem
pe locul ăsta până până la final, pentru
că oricum este ultima zi de pescuit,
este ora 2:00 și poate reușim totuși să
scoatem ceva mai mare.
Deci vine o super furtună. A fost una
mai devreme
mai
cumințică. Deci, se vede cerul. Este
efectiv negru în fața noastră și în
stânga și în dreapta și vine vine repede
spre noi. Asta e.
Poate furtuna asta aduce peștele mare.
Poate se sperie peștele de pe lacuri și
intră pe canal.
Scoate l din mărăcini.
>> Aia, asta vreau. De asta îl țin.
Cred că aici
>> mărișor. Ă,
>> nu știu.
După o oră, după furtună, a mai venit un
pește. Ăsta pare un pic mai îmbrăcat
și hai să l și vedem
cum e. Am scăpat de
Da, da. E mai frumușel ăsta,
dar dă din cap destul de agresiv și asta
îmi spune că nu este prea mare. Pune l
aici, Narcis, pe partea asta.
Îl pe deasupra mea și lasă l, lasă l
aici jos. O să l scot eu.
Dar sunt foarte agresivi ăștia.
După cum vedeți, am un super drill cu
el.
Superb, mă. Superb, superb.
Și pentru asta venim în Delta Dunării,
mă băieți, pentru drillurile astea
superbe. Ia uitați vă și voi.
Mamă, și apa e curată. Voi nu l vedeți,
dar eu îl văd cum ajunge la suprafață.
Iar se duce.
Uite și tu unde s a dus.
Deci uitați vă câtă putere are. Bă, nu
mi vine să cred. Are
>> 5 kg zici tu, Narcis?
Ă,
așa zici?
>> Hai să vedem. Deci, mă trage cu barcă.
Uită te și tu.
Bine, mă. Frumos.
Hai sus. Mă lipă. Nu
trage cu obosește singur.
Acuma trebuie să l lăsăm să obosească.
Nu, lasă, lasă că mă descurc.
S a dus în stuf,
na.
Nu pot să l iau. Ia vezi, Narcis, poți
să l iei tu din stuf.
Acum, acum. Bravo, bravo. Gata, gata, nu
ne grăbim.
Deci, dragi pescari, pe ploaie, ia
uitați vă și voi ce mustăcios frumos a
venit. Cred că are vreo 4 kg, 4G5.
Și uitați vă ce plouă.
Hai,
îl iei? Îl aduci tu.
>> Adu
>> trebuie să l trec peste cioată, să știi
>> cum
>> trebuie să l trec peste cioată. Uite l.
>> Uite aici. Așa faci drillul. Îl aduci la
suprafață.
Dragi pescari,
aceeași lansetă, un alt pește.
Acuma dăm peste cioată și se pare că
peștii s au mutat acolo și ăștia sunt și
mai îmbrăcați.
Deci o să scoatem încă o lansetă și o s
o dăm în partea aia să vedem.
Haide, mă. Hai, ia vino tu în partea
asta.
Tot așa, la fel ca ăla.
Ce cumințel vine ăsta vine cuminte,
Narcis.
Ăsta a făcut drillul acolo.
>> Nu intră.
Ia uite cum are ăsta coada.
Mamă,
>> tăiată.
>> Ia să vezi. Ia ține tu la Stai așa.
Stai, stai un pic.
Lasă că o pun aici lanseta. Dă cotorul.
Uite așa,
>> bă. Ăsta, vezi că are, cred că are 7 kg
ăsta. 6 7 kg.
Ia uitați, dragi pescari.
>> Tăiat de o barcă.
>> Ce pește e tăiat de o barcă aici. Hai că
ne uităm imediat.
Ia uitați, dragi pescari, ăsta cred că
are aproape de 7 kg.
Hai să zic un 6:30 și uitați vă ce coadă
tăiată are. Ăsta e pescuitul, dragi
pescari. Asta ne place în Delta Dunării.
Uitați și voi cum este. Vremea. Îi dă și
cu un pic de gheață, grindină. Doar ce
am prins doi pești pe ploile astea. Este
superb.
Dragi pescari, scorul este 14 la 11.
Avem 14 trăsături, dintre care am reușit
să scoatem doar 11, iar ultimii doi au
fost doi pești îmbrăcați, ceea ce ne
bucură foarte mult. Am făcut o mică
modificare.
Până acum am pescuit aici între stuf și
cioată după. Iar acum de o oră și
jumătate n am mai avut trăsături aici și
am lăsat o lansetă peste cioată aproape
de de malul de vizavi și a venit acolo o
trăsătură și am zis dacă mai vine un
pește de acolo o să mai mut o lansetă să
bag tot acolo. Și acuma mai am băgat o
și pe a doua tot acolo și așteptăm să
vedem.
Lanseta de lanseta a doua de la stânga
la dreapta am dat o aproape de stuful
din partea stângă. Am lăsat două aici
aproape de noi. Două sunt peste ciată.
Și acum să vedem de unde vine de vine de
unde vine următoarea trăsătură.
>> De aici. Așa.
>> Ia dreapta, dreapta. Hai, ia l, ia, ia l
că i acolo.
Bravo. Cum e?
Vezi să nu se ducă niciodată. Vezi să nu
se ducă niciodată. Du te urcă te sus
acolo.
A mai venit un ciortănaș. 15
cât?
>> 16.
>> Păi nu 16 12
>> 12
>> Deci 16 trăsături.
>> 16 trăsături. 12 pești scoși. 12 pești
scoși.
Bă, dar ce coadă roșiatică la pește care
i roșu? Femela sau masculul?
>> Nu contează. Ambii. Ambi, depinde cu ce
se hrănesc
>> de obicei. Da, da, da. Lasă.
>> Du te, du te pe
>> A, am A plecat cu ea. Bă,
>> e în
>> E în cioată
ăsta.
Ia l, ia l, ia l, ia l. E acolo.
Este.
>> Da. Hai că l las pe ăsta aici.
Dragi pescari, dublu drill, 18
trăsături, unul a intrat în ciată
și Narcis acum se ocupă de altul.
Un ciortănaș.
>> E strânsă tare. Da,
e strânsă tare frâna.
strânge
un pic
Ia
stai să mă ridic eu peste.
Ridică lanseta peste mine.
Dragi pescari, a mai venit unul, am
ratat unul. Asta este. Îi dăm înainte.
Mai avem o oră de pescuit și vedem ce
mai intră.
Mi a dat cu coada direct. [sforăit] Ah,
>> ai văzut ce mi a făcut și m a lovit
peste față.
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> Gata, dragi pescari. Partida noastră s a
încheiat. După ce termin de vorbit în
fața camerei o să strâng lansetele și o
să plecăm o luăm spre Mila 23. A fost o
partidă efectiv cu de toate. A fost o
partidă în care am alergat foarte mult
după pește. Am prima zi efectiv am
consumat mulți litri de benzină.
A doua zi
n am avut n am avut cine știe ce
activitate. Am scos doar doi ciortani
parcă am avut patru trăsături și am avut
doi ciortani scoși. Iar astăzi a fost o
zi, din punctul meu de vedere, super
reușită. Am avut în total scoși 13
pești. 13 sau 14 pești și mai mari și
mai micuți. Niciunul nu a depășit, zic
eu, 6 kg, 6,5 pe acolo.
Dar pe praful ăsta, pe și pentru faptul
că ieri n am avut activitate și alaltă
ieri n am avut activitate, a fost foarte
foarte bine. Acum două zile a fost super
cald. Ă, ieri a început să se răcească
un pic și astăzi a fost rece. Nu mi am
dat costumul de iarnă deloc de pe mine
când a plouat, când a dat cu grindină,
când a fost soare, când și tot așa s a
repletat ciclul ăsta. În ciuda acestor
lucruri
am avut activitate. Da, cam asta este
despre partida de astăzi. Văd că avem o
ciupitură pe lanseta [voce dreasă] din
dreapta. Cam asta este pentru partida pe
care am avut o în perioada asta. Este
ultima partidă până în prohibiție. O să
înceapă prohibiția. Două luni de zile o
să stăm o să stăm degeaba. Mă rog, o să
stăm degeaba. Eu o să eu o să merg în
continuare la pescuida pe bălți și o să
merg la feeder să facem și acolo un pic
de promovare. Produsele bineînțeles că
le știți ca de fiecare dată. cirașa de
pe tort, peletă de 15 mm, mai mult 15 mm
am folosit partida asta și nada pe
monuitor, nada nouă, ediție specială
care a adus rezultate și de data asta.
De data asta am avut mai multe rezultate
la căpșună.
Hai să zicem că poate să fie o
coincidență că am avut mai multe
rezultate la căpșună. Am avut și pe
Secret Arom, am avut și pe galben. Așa
că, na, nu putem să zicem că peștele a
preferat căpșuna. Narcis este de altă
părere. N ar zice că a preferat căpșuna.
Ok. Bun. Cam asta. Cam asta este tot. La
început de sezon o să avem ceva surprize
pentru voi. O să avem niște produse noi.
Îmi doresc să scot bilele Delta Activ și
de căpșună și o să avem riguri direct
legate pentru momitor de 10, de 6 și de
18 și de nu de 10, de 8 și de 6 și
riguri de 20 cm pentru plumb pierdut sau
plumb in line cu cârlige de 20 cu
cârlige de 6 și de patru, poate chiar și
de doi. Cam astea o să fie noutățile.
Poate dacă mai reușim să facem și
altceva, o să anunț o să anunț pe
clipuri. Cei care sunteți clienții
noștri și doriți să intrați în grupul
nostru de WhatsApp, unde discutăm despre
pescuitul în Delta Dunării, este un grup
special pentru Delta Dunării, puteți să
mă contactați la numărul de pe site, să
mi scrieți pe WhatsApp. Condiția este să
fiți clientul nostru, să folosiți
produsele noastre și bineînțeles o să vă
dăm un set de reguli minime pe care
trebuie să le respectați. Cam atât a
fost în acest sezon scurt până în
prohibiție. Am avut trei ieșiri în Delta
Dunării. În toate pot să zic că am avut
succes și așteptăm să vină vara. Vă
salut și ne vedem din
iunie. Yeah.